DANA HAN-KLEIN: Hi
everyone Hi everyone.
Welcome to Talk at Google.
My name's Dana
Han-Klein, and today it
is my pleasure to
welcome some of the cast
and the executive
producer of "Code Black."
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH: Hi.
MELANIE CHANDRA: Hi.
HARRY FORD: Hi.
RYAN MCGARRY: Hi guys.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So "Code
Black"-- gritty, gross,
awesome.
Ryan, did you want
to tell us about what
inspired this in your journey,
and how this became, now,
a television show?
RYAN MCGARRY: Yeah.
I was on day one of a medical
school rotation at the LA
County Hospital.
And I was in this very
special trauma bay.
And I thought, within
about 30 seconds, I'm like,
I don't think America's ever
seen anything like this before.
Every five seconds, there's
every aspect of human drama
that's coming in here--
life, death, first chances,
second chances, last chances.
I mean, it's totally phenomenal.
And there was no shortage
of characters in the doctors
and nurses who gave that care.
And I thought, this is a film.
This is going to be a film.
And I'd always wanted to combine
storytelling and medicine.
And so I found myself
with a documentary
that long story short, went into
the festivals and the theaters.
And now is the premise
for this incredible show
with these incredible cast.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Right.
Can you also explain what
a code black is for those
who are not in the know yet?
RYAN MCGARRY: Yeah.
So a code block is, technically,
an internal disaster.
And some hospitals call
it something different .
On our show, a code block
means that there is basically
an influx of patients that's
so great that there aren't
enough resources to treat them.
But I think what the
show really is about,
is it's really sort of
putting you as the viewer
into the co-pilot
seat as a new doctor,
basically going along with
these guys on their shift.
It's breathless.
It's breathtaking.
I think you kind of sweat
through the episode at times
because it's so intense.
And I think you're going to end
the show feeling like OK, that
was an experience.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah.
I think it was great that
you guys didn't shy away
from-- hospitals get
glamorized a lot I feel like.
And this was very
gory and visceral.
And so for you guys,
how has this experience
been as actors, kind of
being put in the set.
My understanding is that
some of the background
cast members are
actual doctors as well.
MELANIE CHANDRA: Sure.
So we wanted to get the
hospital environment
as real as possible.
It was actually mirrored
after LA County Hospital.
So even if you opened drawers,
you opened the refrigerator,
you have all these gross
things and posters peeling off.
So it's really
gritty and rustic.
And yeah, we have hundreds
of extra on set every day.
So even if you're
just doing a scene,
and there's just one gurney and
a couple nurses and doctors,
you still have hundreds
of patients and doctors
roaming back and forth.
And they've hired real
medical personnel and staff
to be those background actors
to create that real environment.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
Yeah, I mean
it's kind of crazy
at the end of a day
because we are surrounded with
so many extras and the set.
We shot the first episode--
which you saw-- on location.
So that was actually
in an actual hospital
that Ryan was referring to.
So that was crazy because
you feel like you spend
16 hours in an emergency room.
And you really did feel,
like a lot of times,
I think we had to go
home and remind ourselves
that we didn't just save lives.
Because it really feels
like that when you're in it,
you know?
HARRY FORD: Louis calls
it medical NASCAR.
And his running joke is, at
any given moment he'll say,
I just show up for a shift.
And I think it does feel like--
as much as laypeople can--
that we're showing
up for a shift,
hopefully to tell the
real heroes' stories,
which is Ryan and these other
nurses and doctors that we met.
RYAN MCGARRY: And I think
we, on the creative side
of the process, I think we felt
that a lot of medical dramas,
the hospital sort of looks
like this incredible office.
Which is not true
to real life, right?
I mean, I feel like if your
hospital looks like a Google
office, we've either come
a long way in this country
or the miracle health care.
HARRY FORD: And I
want to be a doctor.
RYAN MCGARRY: Yeah, exactly.
Or we're not being authentic.
And so I think we
went to great strides
to make the focus of
the show, interestingly,
not about medical
technology, not
about touch screens and all
these futuristic things that we
see in medical shows
that in some ways
sort of take the doctor
away from the patient.
We were all about the
touch of it, really
that moment of
having to connect.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: My understanding
is that you guys went
through a medical boot Camp
HARRY FORD: Oh yeah.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
What was that like?
HARRY FORD: I'm certified now.
I have offices hours
on the weekends.
MELANIE CHANDRA:
Ryan, didn't you
say we have enough hours of
training that we could actually
be EMTs?
RYAN MCGARRY: Yeah,
at this point--
MELANIE CHANDRA:
Which is just scary.
RYAN MCGARRY: --and I'm not
talking about just on set time,
but the amount of time
that these guys have
spent as far as their actual
medical hands on training.
At this point, they'd be
equivalent in the state
of California to
EMTs, and soon would
be on their way to
paramedic level training
as far as hours spent.
HARRY FORD: Holy cow.
RYAN MCGARRY: And
it's really true.
I mean, we go to great
lengths on the show
to portray to the public
the real way to do CPR.
So on medical dramas,
you'll see a lot
of this, which is all in
the elbows and doesn't work.
The right way is in the
shoulders and using your back.
And if it's working,
well you guys
know, it cracks people's chests.
So we have to put protective
plates over our actors
who are the patients,
which is incredible.
HARRY FORD: We had a rehearsal
today right before we came.
I was with Raza, and he
and I found ourselves
going, oh right.
If this is the case, if
the blood pressure's this,
that means there must
be bleeding down low.
And if that means, that's
why the heart is slowed down.
And somebody just looked
at us and was like what?
You guys are not doctors.
But you do.
You find yourself wanting
to understand the medicine
because it informs the thinking.
You know, it informs
the thinking and how
you are, and authenticity.
I think that's a
big focus for us.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
It's very method.
It is, which is
wonderful to see.
It's not just this kind
of, oh, I'm showing up
and I'm saving the day, and
I've solved it with a diagnosis
that Sherlock Holmes did.
MELANIE CHANDRA: And
we also did ride alongs
with ER doctors at night just
to talk to the residents,
talk to the nurses,
talk to the staff,
and just understand the
dynamics and some of the issues
they face.
And I don't know, it was really,
really informative for me.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
I think we
got the sense of their
attitudes, especially.
Because you know, I
think hopefully what
we brought is a different
flavor of characters
that you normally wouldn't
think would be doctors.
And they are.
And that's what you
see in real life.
You go in an emergency
room, and your doctor
doesn't look like a doctor.
He looks like a person,
because he is a person, or she.
And I think that was
really important to us.
And I think one thing
with the authenticity
thing, the closer we could
come to portraying something
that you would find in
any urban hospital ER,
the more we're hoping
the general public
would resonate with them and
their experiences in there.
Because I think everyone's
had a traumatic experience
in their life where they've
gone to the hospital.
And they've been
in the waiting room
when someone who is just
a wreck rolls through
on a gurney from a
massive car accident.
And that feeling of when your
hair goes stands on its end,
and you're like oh wow,
stuff's getting real.
That's what we try to create.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: What's one of
the most interesting things
you've learned from kind of
interacting with these other?
I mean obviously,
you work with Ryan,
but there's probably
a difference.
MELANIE CHANDRA: Well,
throughout the series,
sometimes you can't
save a patient's life.
So one of the first questions
I asked a fourth year
resident was, can you tell
me about the first time
a patient has died on you?
And sometimes you
see doctors as very,
they've put up these
barriers because they
have to do their job.
But I could just
see in her eyes when
she was telling this story that
it still deeply affected her.
And so as actors, it's
all about the empathy,
but still being professional.
And so it's great to see that
human connection very much
exists and is alive
in these people.
HARRY FORD: Yeah, I struggle
with the, I would say,
requirement to
compartmentalise how you feel
vs what you observe.
And Ryan has a great story
that I'll let him tell.
But there are moments where
your humanity wants to lead you.
And the minute that
happens, you're compromised.
And as Harry, I find myself
going, this is impossible.
I cannot ignore such and
such and such and such.
And so I think leading
with the observation,
and the information,
and the science,
and the technology is
an extraordinary thing.
Because it's backwards to me.
Especially at Google,
I go I don't even
know how to use a phone.
That kind of thing,
it's all foreign to me.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH: We do
have real ultrasound machines
on set.
So when we put an ultrasound
wand to someone chest,
we see what's inside, like
actually, a lot of time.
If you were here,
I'd be like whomp.
And you can see it
up on the screen.
So it's cool.
I mean, I think we found out--
HARRY FORD: And you
learned not to comment
because you have no idea what--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
Congratulations on your--
RYAN MCGARRY: You never know.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
What's that big white blob?
MELANIE CHANDRA:
I think even when
we're taking people's
blood pressure,
the cuffs, those are real too.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
Of course, yeah.
MELANIE CHANDRA: We
had this like patient
who was an extra on set.
And when they knew the camera
was going to be on them,
their blood pressure
would keep spiking.
So we actually had to
fake the monitor because--
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
We couldn't play.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Hey, I get
nervous around doctors.
That happens to me.
So clearly this
person was very much
actually in the
moment with you guys.
It sounds like that leads
to a lot of mischief
though, having actual
equipment on set.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
Mischief on "Code Black" set?
No-- no.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: None
whatsoever, ever.
Well, let's talk about your
characters for a moment.
Because it's one, great to see a
nice and diverse cast up there.
It's nice to see a lot
of women leads, which
is nice and
representative I think
of more of our actual
medical profession.
I'm going to start
with you Harry.
Your character goes
through something,
I feel like at least having
watched pilot, that we
experience a lot of Google.
It's imposter syndrome.
HARRY FORD: Oh, that's
what we call it, yeah.
He, yes-- yes.
And I the actor am
waiting for someone
to come and tap
me on the shoulder
and say OK, get out of here.
You slipped through the cracks.
And I think, luckily, I
have that track in the show.
I often joke I'm playing
Ryan, and he hates that.
But it's just--
RYAN MCGARRY: It's
completely baseless.
HARRY FORD: It's because
I'm not as pretty as he is.
And I'm like look, give
me a little credit.
But I feel like Angus's struggle
is a lot of people's, which
is he has the information.
He has the passion.
He knows what to do.
But he doesn't have the
courage and the bravery
to find his voice
to speak his truth.
And in that sense, I think
it's a universal problem.
But it's definitely
imposter syndrome.
And I come from a long line of
successful people in medicine.
So it's also this--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: You've
been researching this.
HARRY FORD: External pressure.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Melanie,
so your character
is one who doesn't necessarily
have imposter syndrome.
She knows what she's doing
but isn't really, at least
in the first episode,
hasn't been given the chance
to kind of show her stuff.
But one thing I love is,
instead of withholding
this information,
lives are at stake.
So she's going to feed
it to a character who
is going to use it.
But where is something you'd
like to see your character grow
to with that?
MELANIE CHANDRA: Sure.
So yeah, in the pilot, you
see that she's very smart.
She knows what she's doing.
She's very experienced.
And she just wants to
prove yourself, right?
And she's just got
a great degree.
You find out she
went to Stanford.
And she's very well educated.
But I think she's learning
to not always follow
the rules when a patient's
life is at stake.
I think she is kind
of the know it all,
and she's always
played by the books.
And so I think it's a matter
of her coming out of her shell.
What you also learn about
her-- and this is not a spoiler
by any means-- but
she's also a lesbian.
So what it means to be-- first
and foremost, she's a doctor.
But then she's also
this-- she's very
confident about her sexuality.
And I think she helps bring up
the morale with the group too.
So she's not just, I'm going
to stay in my own world.
She wants the team to win.
And I think that's a really
inspiring aspect about her.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: And then
your character, Ben, is a--
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH: Dick?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: That was
actually in my notes.
I didn't want to say it that
way, but I was like, he is--
but I was watching the episode--
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
He's so likable.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: --rough
around the edges.
Let's go rough around the edges.
HARRY FORD: Ryan just
said Ben plays him.
RYAN MCGARRY: Yeah, can
we go to a close up here.
Right here, close up right here.
Angus Leighton is not
Ryan McGarry in real life.
It is a baseless claim.
I just want to put it out there
to the interwebs in case that
happens again.
Now however, Mario
Savetti may be.
I don't know.
There might be some
similarities here.
He's jacked, good
looking dude over there.
I don't know.
I'm just saying.
He's aggressive.
He gets after the cases.
I don't know.
There might be some--
HARRY FORD: I'm going to be
America's sweetheart though,
so you better back
that talk back.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: You
just said, he can split.
That's kind of the joy of being
an EP is that you get to be
like, you're both my character.
HARRY FORD: No, he's like 0%.
RYAN MCGARRY: 0%
American and world.
HARRY FORD: Great.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
You heard it here.
HARRY FORD: Yeah,
what a charmer.
What a charmer.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So what's that
additional responsibility like
then, playing the--
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
Playing the bad boy?
I guess it's fun.
It's nice to not have
to apologize for things
that your character
doesn't feel like he
should have to apologize for.
And I think it
gives me somewhere
to go as far as an actor
and playing an overall arc.
I think obviously
there's going to be
some reasons why Mario is a
little confident and a little
cocky.
And I think hopefully
you'll see that
throughout the first
season, kind of learn
some lessons along
the way, and hopefully
be a better doctor for it.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: And become
this super likable teddy bear.
But it's great.
Sometimes we all just
want to say the things
that-- we don't want a filter.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH: I
mean, that's very human.
I mean, I think
Mario says the things
that a lot people say behind the
doors or behind people's backs.
And I think there's
something to be
said about a character
that is just going
to say it to someone's face.
Listen, you're 10
years older than me.
That's what it is.
I mean, you're not, but
I think in the pilot
when he gives Krista's
character shit, that's
what he's referring to.
I can say shit, right?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah, totally.
HARRY FORD: Well
said Ryan, well said.
RYAN MCGARRY: What's
weird is some people
stop me in the street.
They're like, you look
like Ben Hollingsworth.
I'm like, I know.
It's weird.
I don't know, I get that a lot.
MELANIE CHANDRA: They have
a very similar jaw lines.
RYAN MCGARRY: It's really
yeah, that jaw line.
HARRY FORD: That happens a lot.
RYAN MCGARRY: It's really weird.
HARRY FORD: That
happens all the time.
RYAN MCGARRY: They're like
yeah, look at those arms dude.
HARRY FORD: Yeah, you can
hardly go down the street.
That's what I heard.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Ryan, was
there a lot of oversight
into the casting
of Ben on this one?
Were you like--
HARRY FORD: Well clearly.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
--I need it to be.
HARRY FORD: Golly.
This has been very
informative, Dana.
I'm really glad we're on.
This has been
really informative.
DANA HAN KLEIN: This is
more of a psychological talk
at this point.
We're diving deep.
So I think to me, one of
the things about ER doctors
is there's this sort of quality
and maybe craziness that
sets them apart, and
like a willingness
to jump into a situation that
maybe-- all doctors provide
wonderful valuable services.
But there is a certain
kind of heroic nature
to being an ER doctor where you
are in the grind and the gunk.
What's something that you are
all inspired by in that role?
HARRY FORD: Within the
first two or three days,
we were on set for the pilot.
We ran into a number of doctors
that had worked with Ryan,
or that had supervised
Ryan, and nurses
that had worked with him.
And every one of
them was completely
moved to tears at saying, thank
you for telling our story.
And we can't tell you
how grateful we are
that you're giving us a voice.
And that, for me, I just keep
coming back to that and going,
that's my goal.
So I think in terms
of the authenticity
and the medical NASCAR and all
that, at the end of the day,
it's to give voice to
people who are the heroes.
They're doing the real stuff.
And for me, there is an
adrenaline thing, because I go,
you're not a podiatrist--
no offense to podiatrists--
but you know, it's
not about hurt feet.
It's about, oftentimes,
what, two minutes?
RYAN MCGARRY: This guy
in row three is pissed.
Sorry man.
HARRY FORD: Sorry.
Sorry about that.
I bet you're a
great foot doctor.
You know, her shoe
broke on the way over.
Maybe you can help her.
But I think there is
something to them.
Because I'd look at it
and go, this is insane.
You people are crazy.
And they love 24 hour shifts.
RYAN MCGARRY: Well I don't
know about love, but--
HARRY FORD: Well no, but
they're like, yeah man,
you're on that's 16th hour.
You don't know
what you're doing.
But it's great to get in there.
And you're just like, what
are you talking about?
This is amazing.
RYAN MCGARRY: I'd
love it if we had
one of those Google kitchens.
We wouldn't be seeing patients.
We'd just be in that
kitchen the whole time.
HARRY FORD: And that hammock.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
Are we 150 feet
away from food right now?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: We're about
50 feet away from food.
HARRY FORD: Of course
they know that.
That's amazing.
Are we 100 feet?
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
I think we're close.
I can see food.
HARRY FORD: Yeah, there's
a coffee bar right there.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
It's pretty good.
MELANIE CHANDRA: One of
things I'm inspired by--
HARRY FORD: Sorry Melanie.
MELANIE CHANDRA: Oh sorry.
HARRY FORD: She's
bringing us back here.
MELANIE CHANDRA: I
actually really like
those cookies that were out
there in the coffee area.
HARRY FORD: Oatmeal raisin.
MELANIE CHANDRA: Did
you know-- I mean,
you guys know-- but you can
just lift up the whole shield
and you can just
take the cookies.
HARRY FORD: You don't even
have to swipe your phone.
MELANIE CHANDRA: You
don't have to ask them.
And that's just so
bizarre and amazing to me.
HARRY FORD: I feel like
I was stealing actually.
MELANIE CHANDRA: Yeah, me too.
HARRY FORD: Do they
notice I've taken three?
MELANIE CHANDRA: But going
back to your question,
one of the things I'm inspired--
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
I was wondering what
that bulge was in your pocket.
Right there.
MELANIE CHANDRA: Good
thing I don't have pockets,
because that would be dangerous.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH: So
we're allowed to be like that?
HARRY FORD: So
Google, thank you.
We had such a nice time here.
So we're going--
RYAN MCGARRY: Check please.
MELANIE CHANDRA: Today,
everyone is like, where
did all the cookies go?
He's low in cookies.
But no, Ryan has this
really inspiring story
about that person
at the airport who
was basically on death's bed.
And you realize some
of these ER doctors,
when they don't have
family or friends around,
are their last point of contact.
And that last point of contact
that can either save their life
or be there when
their life ends.
And I don't know if you
want to tell this story,
but I just love this story.
RYAN MCGARRY: Yeah,
we always say there's
a weird intimacy to this world.
And for what it is, it's
kind of like a blue collar
medicine in that we're often on
shifts no one wants to be on.
We're often the only
doctor in the hospital
if it's a smaller
community hospital
on a holiday and a night shift.
And so there are certain
elements of course
that are not very glamorous.
But there is a weird intimacy
in that when someone comes in,
you may be the very last
person they ever make contact
with in this world.
And it may be one of their
worst days of their life,
or potentially their best.
But you don't know them.
And it may even be
something minor.
I mean, it's not uncommon to
literally go hey, how are you.
I'm Dr. McGarry.
And 30 seconds later, and how
many sexual partners have you
had?
It's insane questions that
you would never ask someone
in the general
public, but you need
to know these things
to grasp their problem
in an efficient way.
But I think the story these
guys are talking about,
which coincidentally happened
on one of my first flight
out to LA from New York
where I was practicing
for a development meeting,
but I'm at LAX baggage claim
at the Starbucks.
And I get this tap
on my shoulder.
And someone's like hey,
does anyone know CPR here?
And I'm like, what?
And sure enough,
in the corner is
this TSA agent who
looks totally ashen gray
and has clearly had
a cardiac arrest.
And I go, I know CPR.
And I go over there and I
start to do compressions.
And you know, now
I'm really into it.
And I'm feeling those
ribs crack and watching
froth gurgle out of his mouth.
And I see his pupils
aren't moving.
And I'm like, this probably
isn't going very well.
And in the interim
while the police
are going to get the shock
device-- which by the way,
definitely can save lives.
So always think of that if
you're in the situation.
I see his cell phone
pop out of his pocket,
and it's those three little dots
that indicate someone's typing.
And it's like, hey, hello,
question mark, question mark.
Are you there?
Hey man, you there?
And it was just the
ultimate moment for me
or reminding myself
of like, my goodness.
No one else in this world
knows this guy has now
lost the pulse.
This I think was his
girlfriend who was just
in mid-conversation with him.
And I'm a complete stranger.
And I know something
she doesn't know.
And this is just unbelievable.
Now, we shocked him and
we got a pulse back.
And I think he at least
lived to the hospital.
I don't know what happened
to him after that.
But it's just a
striking example of how
you don't have to do a lot
of hyperbole or dramatization
of this world to make
something incredibly intense
and engaging.
And I think my vouch to anybody
who watches "Code Black"--
and I think the cast would
agree-- I mean, it's authentic.
What you're seeing is real.
And I don't think anyone's
ever seen him like it before.
Because we don't have to
Hollywoodize these stories.
I mean, it's just
really intense as is.
And it's totally real.
HARRY FORD: Something
that I remember
is when we were
first there, I said,
do you ever feel like
you've lost patients,
or you can't save them?
And it was Billy.
Billy goes, well, when
they come in, they're dead.
They're already dead.
So you can do no harm, right?
That's the first
rule is do no harm.
But he's like at the end
of the day, they come in
and they're dead.
So anything you do is
actually going to help them.
And you know, there
are exceptions.
But I think that's
an extraordinary role
to play in someone's life, that
you're their last best hope,
really, I think, hopefully.
Unless Mario's your doctor, then
it's all downhill from there.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I
think it's something
we all hope for when we
get a doctor that they
care enough to.
Your life is in their hands.
MELANIE CHANDRA: Or
that they look like him.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Or both, you know.
On a slightly lighter
note, if you all
had to specialize in medicine,
what would you choose?
You yourself, not
your character's.
Podiatry is an OK answer.
HARRY FORD: Yeah, thank you.
As a young kid, I
always wanted to be
a cardiovascular
pediatric surgeon.
I know that's so specific,
but I remember it
because the first time
I went to the hospital,
I saw these little
bitty preemies
that were hooked up
to these machines.
And I said I want to be
the guy who does that.
And I didn't know what it meant.
And then they told me I
was too stupid to do it.
But I always wanted to do that.
And I joke with Ryan that
I think Angus is secretly
a pediatrician.
But that was not a popular
answer with any of them,
pediatrics.
Children I think.
MELANIE CHANDRA: I want
to say pediatrics too,
but I'll also say neurology.
I come from a techie background.
And if I could have
gone back in time--
I actually got my
degree in engineering.
But if I could have
gone and done it again,
it would have been in
neuroscience and symbolic
systems.
Because I'm just--
HARRY FORD: And what?
MELANIE CHANDRA:
Symbolic systems,
just because I'm just--
HARRY FORD: What does that mean?
MELANIE CHANDRA: --fascinated by
the way things work, and logic,
and problem solving, and
just that whole arena.
HARRY FORD: Wait, no
really, what does-- You all
know what that means but me?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: You should
Google it, is my answer
to that.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
Yeah, Google it Harry.
HARRY FORD: Well, I can't.
I don't have my phone.
Do you all know what that means?
Everyone?
You know?
Is that a Google thing?
AUDIENCE: Well, I
have an AI background.
HARRY FORD: What does that mean?
AUDIENCE: Artificial
intelligence.
HARRY FORD: I'm an idiot.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
Welcome to Google.
HARRY FORD: I'm a
technological idiot.
RYAN MCGARRY: I'm not joking.
There is a dog back there,
and he knows what it is.
Am I crazy?
Did a dog just walk back there?
Are we taking
questions in a second,
because that dog had a question.
HARRY FORD: The good new is, I'm
not afraid to say I don't know.
I don't know.
RYAN MCGARRY: Oh yeah, look at.
There it is.
There is a dog.
He knows what that is.
HARRY FORD: Do you know
the symbolic system thing?
MELANIE CHANDRA: Yeah,
anyway, so that would
be my brainiac sort of answer.
I think it's interesting.
HARRY FORD: That was well done.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH: I
think I'm an adrenaline guy.
I would love to work in trauma.
You know, I think the--
HARRY FORD: Did
you say podiatry?
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
Trauma-- trauma.
MELANIE CHANDRA:
General and podiatry.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH: I
think the amount of people
that you get to work
on the front lines
with-- it's a team
environment, which I love.
And the fact that
you have to make
instinctual-- you have to
make life or death decisions.
And you have to do it
based on your instincts
and what you believe.
I think that's exciting.
And I would be able to do that
for a very long time, until I
was worn out.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: That's awesome.
HARRY FORD: No symbolic
systems for you.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH: No.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Maybe.
Maybe you can retire
to symbolic systems.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH: That and
I can get my like workout just
doing chest compressions.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: There you go.
Correctly.
Doing them correctly.
And then my other question--
RYAN MCGARRY: Yeah.
I know it's hard to get there.
But keep working.
Some day buddy.
HARRY FORD: Do you want
to sit closer to him?
You want to move?
Golly.
RYAN MCGARRY: Can
that dog come up here?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: And if you had
to have one of your peers--
Ryan does not count-- be
your doctor in an emergency
situation, who would--
MELANIE CHANDRA: Only like
these three colleagues?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: No,
anyone on the cast.
Anyone on the cast.
And not an actual doctor.
HARRY FORD: Well what
about these three?
MELANIE CHANDRA: Well
there's my answer.
HARRY FORD: None of us?
MELANIE CHANDRA: No, I
mean, you guys are great.
HARRY FORD: Think about
all of our time together.
I have not been wrong.
MELANIE CHANDRA:
You have not been.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
He did win that contest.
HARRY FORD: I have
not been wrong.
I have been bullied,
but I've not been wrong.
MELANIE CHANDRA: His character,
even though he's still
like learning how
to have conviction,
he's usually pretty right.
His instincts are right.
But I think Marcia, I
think Marcia Gay Harden
would actually make a really
great, great, great doctor
because she's so smart.
She's always on top of it.
But she's so compassionate
at the same time.
I would trust her.
HARRY FORD: I think
I'd want Raza.
RYAN MCGARRY: I would want Raza.
Yeah.
Marcia-- yeah.
It's funny.
I think I'd want Marcia to
explain a diagnosis to me.
And then I feel like Raza
can execute and do surgery.
HARRY FORD: I would
want her to explain it.
That's right.
Not Kevin.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
HARRY FORD: No, not Dr. Taylor.
No.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
You're going to die tomorrow.
Deal with it.
Who would I pick
out of the cast?
I mean, Raza is
the obvious choice
because he's so-- I think
the accent makes everything.
MELANIE CHANDRA:
Because he's British.
HARRY FORD: I trust him more.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
You know what?
I think I would go
with-- I think I would go
with Luis, just as a curveball.
HARRY FORD: She said doctor.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
Well, you know, she
said who out of the peers.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: He thought
outside the box on that answer.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
Yeah-- yeah.
Just because I think
that if Luis studied
his entire life
of being a doctor,
he would know it inside and out.
HARRY FORD: But he didn't.
But he didn't.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
Are we assuming
that we're all doctors in this?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yes,
in this scenario.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH: We're
assuming that we all have
our MDs like actual doctors.
HARRY FORD: Would
you pick me second?
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH: I
wouldn't pick you second.
You would be in the
top five though.
Top four, maybe.
MELANIE CHANDRA: Out of eight.
BENJAMIN HOLLINGSWORTH:
Out of eight.
Top 50%, that's not bad.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Top 50%.
Well, thank you all so
much for joining us today.
"Code Black" is on
CBS.